The joe rogan experience.
John Fraser was a motherfucker.
How sad wasn't we used to go to Philly.
Lisa drive passage gym on the way from the airport that nae,
but he lived at his gym before he died.
Yeah,
he went broke in the end.
Look,
the amount of money that these guys make for the time,
look,
they're talking to my $5 million persons for Ali informant for the time you have
$5 million back then.
That is a lot of goddamn money.
But guess what?
You live like you've got $5 million.
So you're buying fucking Cadillacs and paying for this and paying for that meals
here and jets there and next thing you know,
$5 million doesn't even make it to the 80s and you know the brothers are showing
up at the door though.
My last motherfucking cousin.
Yeah,
listen man,
we got to venture and this mother fucker can't go wrong.
Bottom shot.
White neighborhood first year going to make 30% of your investments.
Second year,
60% on Yelp.
That's Matt.
And it just hit you with some crazy speech.
How many of those do you ever had to deal with?
Three.
Oh,
you got them all the time.
I had to deal with one recently.
Movies,
TV shows you get them constantly ear beatings to isn't I even come this man,
I'm not a movie producer.
All you have to do
is give us a check and we'll do it.
Oh,
she don't have to do anything you don't have to worry about.
Yes I do.
I have to worry about it.
No,
no,
no.
You don't have to worry about it.
No,
no.
I do have to worry about it.
If I give you money,
I'm gonna worry about it.
Get out of here where your crazy idea.
This is the reason why they have banks.
Okay,
go to the bank.
If you have a really good idea and you have credit,
go to the fucking bank.
If you don't have credit,
I got to assume somewhere along the line you've already made some poor fucking
choices.
I don't want to be involved in that.
People have this,
everybody has this idea that they,
they're gonna figure out how to circumvent this time honored system of
Hollywood.
And we're going to get to Joe Diaz.
If I can get to Cho Diaz.
I know Jody has been killing it on the road.
If he can give me just $2,000 and I could start this film.
You know Quentin Tarantino does it.
Burn,
ran,
ran.
Kevin Smith made clerks and man,
man,
man.
And they just think that all they need is a couple grand from Joey Diaz.
Joe,
Joe.
You can't go wrong.
Okay.
Nobody makes movies.
Join.
They just don't want me in.
They don't want me and Joey take,
don't want me and Joey as they want to keep me on the outside.
Well,
you get them for your time.
It's not even that you get them for money.
It's you get them for your time.
Yeah.
Look at you with you're living through you.
You're busy.
Yeah,
you're swamp.
There's no more.
I keep telling people that and they get mad at me.
No,
they don't understand.
When you have children,
there's no schedule.
I can't count on my schedule at 10 20 she wouldn't get off my fucking lap
watching one,
two,
three videos on youtube at 10 30 I went to pick her up like,
let's go with what?
Yeah,
what will you fucking talking about?
Like I'll be back in a couple of hours talking.
You don't have no fucking idea what it is to,
and I went to get to go into the room at nine 30 I get out of it.
I was going to get out of early.
That little bitch open the gate,
Doug.
I heard those stomping and like this.
There's no arguing,
but she just puts her hands up.
Got To pick her up,
got to put youtube on.
I got to sit there with a one,
two,
three,
four,
five you know,
and then she again,
Daddy.
Okay,
well the the problem people asking you to do things too is that you kind of do
this shit for yourself.
Okay?
The way to do it is not to go through other people and ask people to pick you up
and help you.
That's not how it works.
It doesn't work that way.
And pay.
Everybody thinks they're gonna figure out some fucking choke shortcut cause they
know you or they know this guy or that guy this.
There's no shortcuts in creating something.
Just figure it out.
Bitch.
I love stand up because there's one part of me,
it doesn't need anybody on these.
A notebook right here.
This is my tools for stand up at a person will go,
go to Bob's fucking coffee house on North Hollywood and do three minutes.
You know me,
I don't give a fuck.
When you,
we talked about having a band that somebody came on hand and said that it was
the toughest thing in the world for a band to stay together.
You got four people personalities.
You know you get these people that come to you now and I was breaking it down
from another planet.
They don't say,
hey Joe,
how you doing?
My name is this.
Read my script for you.
Like it.
Yeah,
we're going to get $8 million and then you go,
okay,
when you get it,
call me.
I really liked the script.
Something you're interested in,
whatever,
three days,
all of a sudden you do get a call on the yield and they say,
hey,
we're making a movie,
but guess what?
We didn't get $2 million.
We've got $200,000 so instead of you getting 10,000 a week,
you're going to get a hundred a day and that's going to be a hit.
We're going to make it happen.
Nine out of 10 they run out of money for marketing and editing and the whole
fucking thing.
So your movie ends up in Youtube.
They don't have a legit schedule.
So you have to work Saturdays and fucking Sundays.
You know those people that are involved in those low rent movies,
they're a fucking nightmare and it's their dream.
And I get,
it's your dream,
but don't include me in this fucking thing because you want me to do everything
cheap on my end,
all the hours.
And it's your fucking dream.
If it's that much of your dream,
and do me a favor,
forget the 200 gs.
We got another 300 gs and make this fucking work.
Well,
not only that,
you can find other actors out there that will do it for cheap.
There's people that are out there that just want to act sort of like a comic
would go to an open mic night.
There's certain actors that just want to do something to put it on a real go
find them.
There's a lot of talented people out there that are not working as far as acting
goes,
there's a lot of fucking people that can do it.
There's a lot of times people,
it's just the,
I just have a problem with people like asking you to help them do it.
Like I get it from comics all the time too.
Just looking for a break.
What are you talking about and you're saying you're not,
you're not going to get a break from another comic.
The way you get breaks is by going on stage and being funny.
Like go to an open mic night.
Be Funny.
The club will say,
Hey Joey Diaz,
your fucking funny.
We would like you to come here more often.
The audience really enjoyed you.
Next thing you know,
some manager says,
you know what,
Joey Diaz,
you're really funny.
We would like to,
uh,
think about taking you on as a client and that's how it works.
Like a comic coming along.
It's not going to make you funnier.
And then the people that do that,
they always have a distorted perception of how good they are already.
You know,
those,
those kids that are asking for a break,
the kids that want you to help him,
hey man,
I just need a break.
If I could do a guest set for you,
it really helped me.
Like that's not you don't,
you don't go to the Doug Stan hope show and asked for a fucking guests.
All our Doug,
we'll probably put you up Doug about it.
Alright,
do 15 starting to go up front.
Doug will push a and open micro on his first time on stage.
He'll do that in front of a crowd in Norway or something.
But that Stan Hope,
you know,
uh,
it's not normal.
You have to do you,
it's amazing what people,
you know,
we weren't like that.
Thank God we knew that this took work at hot.
We knew that this wasn't going to happen in one night.
I was old enough already when I started.
I was long in the tooth already that I knew this was just not gonna.
You know,
you just didn't walk on stage and things happen and people come here and they
called desperadoes where they just do,
don't come up to you for a guest and you got to ask them,
what is this going to do for you?
Right?
How's this going to fucking change your life?
It's like I've never been too much of a hanger on it.
I don't believe in that.
I never believed in that shit.
You know?
I believe in doing the spot if I go to the economy.
So it's cause I'm doing a fucking spot.
If I don't go to,
I don't go to the Improv.
My name isn't on that list.
The hangout,
there's no,
for me,
no,
no.
Because if you come up to Joe Rogan,
red band or Jamie and go,
Hi Jamie,
my name is Joey Diaz.
I'm a fucking,
I'm calm.
I'm a funny comic.
Jamie's going to say,
are you going up tonight because we all want to watch it.
I love to laugh.
You're funny.
Let's go.
No,
I'm just here hanging out.
You hate that fucking funny.
If he's not on the list,
you ain't that fucking fun or they don't know about you yet.
There's a possibility that there's certain people that go to the Improv,
that's it,
and they'll tell you,
dog,
you've got a network.
What network?
Your network on stage.
I didn't have work on stage when they laughed when I walk off.
That's networking.
Not only dad.
When you're a comic,
you're sort of like a fruit or a vegetable.
In that year,
you're growing and then you get to one day you going to be ripe and when you're
going to be ripe,
everyone's gonna know about it and people find out about you.
If people found out about everybody,
they found out about you,
they found out about Hinchcliffe.
They find out about everybody.
You hear about Dunkin.
You wouldn't happen to know what's happening in China right now.
What's happening in China?
I was packing them in.
Oh yeah.
Every night.
And he goes,
I can't believe there's white people in UFC fans
coming from money out.
Okay?
They're not big rooms.
There were 120 seat,
a hundred seat.
This is like coffee shops,
right?
But where on the Internet,
this shit is worldwide.
It's worldwide.
He can't believe it.
That there's fucking people walking around here going,
we came to see you from Macau.
I can't believe it took people so long to figure it out.
Or he's a fucking genius.
He's a great comic.
It's,
uh,
it's just amazing that people have misled.
They think there's shortcuts.
When we got here,
what was the shortcut?
If you get on the tonight show,
right?
That's it.
How many people have gone to the tonight show and not great success?
No one cares.
A lot of pee all now it doesn't.
No,
but back in the day it meant something big.
You know,
Steven Wright days,
I could finally do a technical,
get up a Turkish get up.
No,
a technical get up in Jujitsu.
I could finally do it after a year of practicing and hotel rooms.
Five a day I would do on my right side of the family.
You know,
I'm a nut thug,
right?
You do know him.
Retarded half where people know that I'm a little stupid.
I'm Geeky.
I don't like,
I don't like being bad at something.
And since we got the comedy work ethic,
I know that you could turn it anything his wife into something if you just keep
showing up.
Yeah.
If you just,
you don't like the major Jitu has been,
I sucked Joe,
but I could finally do the whole gym hip escape that fucking,
I'm a black belt.
The hip escapes to me today.
That's what I do.
I'm a hip escape expert.
That's what I work on.
You know?
Uh,
it's games a huge fuck.
And when you learn how to do it for you or for six months,
I didn't know what I was doing and it's Alami taught me sometimes all just
taught me a different and I put it all together on my shoulder and now at least
I could pick up my ass and push it all the way back for me.
Those are little things,
you know.
I wish I was better,
but I know if I keep going to Jujitsu twice a week,
which is what my body can handle.
Eventually I'll get it somebody in an arm bar eventually cause I got funny with
Combi.
I was no fucking just slip Magoo in the beginning.
I just,
whatever.
I just kept showing up.
You've just got to keep showing the fuck up.
That's half of life.
That's how a life and who gives a fuck.
I want,
I'm not looking for a black belt.
I'm not even looking to go to a beat.
Nobody up.
I'm just looking to go to learn to a Turkish get up.
I could do with 10 pounds of Turkish get up.
I'm up to this point where I put my arm down,
I put my knee up and I just go up to my elbow and I go down and I do tell her
those bro Bop,
Bop,
bop.
I don't even go off,
but I've been doing it for eight months.
Got Kettlebells,
10 pounds Turkish get up bitch,
but I'm still doing it right.
What would happen if I would took 35 pounds?
You know me dog.
I get it.
I wouldn't be here right now.
My shoulder would be at my fucking hill so,
but at least I know this going in because because of the lesson I got from
comedy that it don't matter though.
Just keep showing up.
Yeah,
but nobody last him dog.
Keep showing him.
Some people you tell them stay home.
Some people just don't want man.
For some people it's like me.
When we did comedy,
there was eight people who had a chance.
That was another six who were funny,
but they had day jobs because they were married or had children.
Then you had two people did it as a hobby that every once in a great while they
drove to a Gig and then you got three people that just had mental health issues.
Yeah.
Okay.
He's always showed up every week and they were nice enough,
but you knew there was something wrong there and for them it was the way this is
for me,
what Jujitsu,
I'm not looking for them.
They're not looking to be on NBC.
All they want to do is one time in their life.
Make somebody laugh.
How special is that?
It's huge.
And they'd go down there and you miss those guys.
I miss those guys from my scenes and see how even here and that way there's
people that you see them and they were a pleasure to talk to because they don't
want an agent.
They don't want to be on movies that just having fun.
They work at universal city in the daytime as the hope,
you know?
It's very few of those that I respect that man are,
they're very,
there's very few of those.
Most of those guys have dreams that just never manifested themselves,
but a lot of them never material.
I met a lot of guys that bro,
they were proud of their job.
They just start somewhere and their life,
I take a be a standup and they just didn't want to die without trying it.
Right.
And then they did it and it become addicted.
How many people go to Jujitsu?
It becomes a daily standup.
Definitely becomes addictive.
It becomes,
it becomes addicting and it's like addicts where you see those guys are
scrambling outside.
The can't wait to get on stage and like even guys who are bad,
they'll see a guy who's up there killing like you be upset killing like man,
he's supposed to only be doing 15 minutes,
motherfuckers at 20 minutes.
Like what do you care?
What are you going to do?
You're going to go up after Joey Diaz,
what are you going to do?
You're an open miker and you're upset.
Like they think somehow or another they,
oh I'm on the non paid regulus but you're not getting up until two in the
morning.
You know how it works.
This is what you do.
You're on a non paid,
I was a non paid regular.
You get up after everybody else.
That's what you do.
If there's anybody fucking crazy is that people should know this.
You want to,
you were on a TV show and you will not pay regular,
which by law if you on a TV show,
you're allowed to go in there and bump bitches.
Give him the bell.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
not only that,
I showed up every night,
every night I was there every night.
Biggest lesson I learned about this whole thing from you.
It was newsradio on Fridays.
You got there at 11 in the morning,
wardrobe,
stupidity,
laughter,
food,
and then at eight o'clock you shoot,
you'd be strolling in there with fucking 1130 bro.
I respect you for that.
So this day that meant more to me and you didn't need it.
And it's $15 it's not like you had 19 kids.
He needed the 15 fucking dollars.
But I'll tell you the truth being passed as a paid regular,
the comic store meant more to me.
Getting on a TV show up.
Me Too.
When I was on a TV show,
when I was on news radio,
one of the things I love about you coming to visit me,
I was like,
finally,
there's another motherfucker.
It doesn't belong here because I was,
I was always wondering around like one day they're going to tell me to get the
fuck off TB,
but until now,
somehow or another,
I'm on TV.
So Joey would show up at black.
Come here man.
Hey,
come here.
Let me show you what this is.
This is where they keep the food
wander around the set.
Joey would show up at the set and Joey will be sitting.
They had an executives,
a VIP suite,
and the VIP suite.
They had shrimp cocktails and delicious hors d'oeuvres,
and they had it catered.
A dude who,
you know,
had like one of those Mumford and sons fucking facial hair things with a
beautiful tie,
a thin,
skinny tie.
He'd be like serving people shit.
And it would be all these NBC executives and Joey fucking Diaz with a leather
jacket,
which stroll in and,
and feast.
He'd be sitting there with a fucking paper plate with like 15 shrimp,
silent,
all my God.
Is that your friend?
Yeah.